The following two equations form a linear system.
This is one equation; it contains x and y,
hence will determine rights.
Then I have another equation that includes x and y,
so it will determine other rights.
It is said: "Draw the system of equations
and found her decision. "
We'll try to find it visually.
Let's draw the first one.
For this right I will use the small drawing tool here.
If I find two points,
I'll be able to move them around
and they will determine the rights.
I will choose two values ​​of x and I will find
the corresponding y values, and then draw the rights.
Let's see how I can do it.
An easy point to find is to see what's going on,
when x is zero?
If x is equal to 0, all that I have marked,
disappears and remains minus 3 is equal to 9.
Then u will be minus 3.
When x is equal to 0, y will be minus 3.
Let me draw it.
When x is equal to 0,
y is minus 3.
Another easy-to-find point will get if instead
to try with another value of x, think what happens when y = 0,
because these equations are normal,
we just have to try.
What are the intersections with the axes x and y?
When y is equal to 0,
this member disappears and you have minus x
is equal to 9 or x will be equal to minus 9.
When
y is 0,
x is minus 9,
or when x is minus 9, y is zero.
Here I introduced the first equation.
Now let's put the second one. We will do the same thing.
What happens when
x is equal to 0,
this will now be intersected with the y axis.
When x is equal to 0, minus 6 is equal to minus 6.
So, y is equal to 1.
Therefore
when x is 0,
y is equal to 1.
Let's find another point here.
When y is 0, when this member is 0,
0 equal to 0 will make this whole article 0,
then 6x is equal to minus 6
or x is equal to minus 1.
When y is 0, x is minus 1,
or when
x is minus 1,
y is 0.
So I did both.
And the solution of the system is x and y values,
which satisfy the two equations, and if they satisfy
both equations, that means they are on both lines.
To be on both lines,
they must be at the point of intersection.
This intersection point is here
it is very clear - this is the point x is equal
to minus 3; y is equal to minus 2.
The point minus 3; minus 2.
Let me write it down.
Minus 3; minus 2.
Then I can check my answer; he is faithful.
Let's solve another problem.
Perhaps a different type.
Here is said: "A system of two linear equations
is outlined below.
Find the approximate solution of the system. "
Okay, I have to look carefully here
and to think where this point is.
Let's first think
for its x value.
It is here over x.
It looks like this is minus 1.
This is minus 2, so minus 1.5
will be right here.
The point is a bit left of minus 1.5,
so it's even more negative, I would say at minus 1.6.
I rounded it down, minus 1.6.
I hope there is some tolerance
when checking the response.
What about the value?
If I look at the value here,
it looks like it's a little less than half past one.
1 and a half will be half between 1 and 2.
It looks like it's a little less than half the distance between
1 and 2 so I'll give her 1.4,
plus 1.4.
And let's check the answer, see how we did.
Yes, it is true.
Let's actually solve one more one.
This is another system.
The equations are written
in the type of tilt-intersection point.
y is equal to minus 7x plus 3.
When x is equal to 0, we have the intersection with y.
y is equal to 3.
When x is equal to 0, y is equal to 3.
Then we see that the slope is minus 7.
When we increase x by 1, we decrease y by 7.
Here we increase x by 1, decreasing y
with 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6 and 7.
When x goes from 0 to 1,
y ranges from 3 to minus 4,
goes down with seven, that's the first point.
Now the second: the intersection with y.
When x is equal to 0, y is minus 3,
let's draw it.
When x is 0, y is equal to minus 3.
And the slope is minus 1.
When x is increased by 1, y decreases by 1.
The slope here is minus 1.
And we got it. We found the crossing point.
You have the pair x; y that satisfies both equations.
This is the point of intersection.
It will lie on both lines,
therefore it is the point of intersection.
And this is the point x is equal to 1,
y is equal to minus 4.
Here, x is equal to 1
and equal to minus 4.
I can check my answer. It is true.